fait de mieux john je suis surtout
wikipédia ouais et c'est le moment de
dire si toutes les infos que j'ai sont
vraies ou fausses wiki ou pas oui qui
est ce que tu fais là meilleure
imitation de l'éternuement de johnny
hallyday c'est vrai ou pas
j'en fais une je passais la meilleure
mais c'est vrai cette histoire tu l'as
dit rencontrer oui j'ai lu j'ai eu la
chance en fait ni en face de lui et donc
les images et des gens qui connaissaient
à un moment donné pendant qu'il parlait
il a éternué et la terre s'arrêter de
tourner à l'envers
c'est sûr que
[Applaudissements]
tout est récent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fanny seco n'a jamais vraiment et
là tu sais que je vous jure que je vais
jetair du paris à oui biensur oui ça me
fait très peur en fait j'adore johnny
moi donc tu vois à quel belle carrière
surtout pas dans ces magnifiques il a
allumé le feu tout je me fous de johnny
moi j'ai toujours été fou de l'état
tamarelle ontarien dray a nommé
jolivet buvait toutes ces
raisons il faut boire
je m'attends avant d'être comédien
réparé et était reconnu comme le roi de
la fenêtre et de l'isolation thermique
alors c'est vrai j'ai une petite
carrière dans des fenêtres a pas duré
longtemps mais j'ai vendu effectivement
des fenêtres en pvc on à lui en boire et
si cesc à targon bien sûr non
ouais j'ai fait ça une petite année puis
après j'ai eu le théâtre qui arrivait
pleine poire et je fais c'était avant de
me connaître ou annoncé avant que koné
louis
enfin peut-être non mais c'est qu il
fallait travailler j'étais en suisse il
était dans la vie active ce qui agite
tout vous dire un truc j admire actif
que ces fenêtres ou des
fous de résistance
en fait c'est un joyau addictif parce
que quand on commence et vous m'avez
envoyé les épisodes et j'en suis déjà au
troisième on ne peut plus s'arrêter la
présentation des candidats le conseil il
ya une épreuve dans l'eau elle dit à
tout le monde quand les preuves dans
l'eau arrivera c'est un moment magique à
des répliques c'est de l'humour c'est
cinglant ses brillants je suis extatique
admiratif de joyaux braves à la merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
et je me saluent les auteurs les jurés
toute l'équipe parce que c'est vrai mais
aussi on retrouve l'esprit canal d'une
époque il ya plus d'émissions d'humour
hélas ce qu'il a fait c'est vraiment
l'esprit canal les attendait j'étais fan
de l'esprit canal a battu par la loi